the jurogan experience i decided not to
go to i could have gone to some of these
places in
scottsdale or la or malibu um and i
could have gotten massages and had the
green smoothies and stuff like that
which
which can help a lot of people but me
after having like a
15 year off and on battle 10 years where
i was i was pretty solid
um and i you know i'd come out of it i'd
get right back on the horse and i'd be
good for
you know years um i
decided i needed fight camp i needed a
training camp i needed
the right coaching the right strategy
and i needed people to
to to ride me like like you know be hard
on me this is
sober yeah this would get sober so
that's that's what i wanted
and so i sought out one of the toughest
places in america to go to
it's kind of a like a 12-step completion
program it's a big book boot camp but
it's also like a uh
it's developed a little bit out of like
militaristic style
and um i was really hard on you you know
i mean while we were there people were
being
called you know masquerading clowns you
fake as [ __ ] [ __ ] and
uh you dr jekyll mr hyde i mean just
like they would just grill people
and you're up at five is that good um i
i i don't i don't know exactly but it
was what i needed at that moment
um is what i need at that moment because
i needed to not
run from it i needed to face it and i
needed to look at the
the stuff are the people running are
people that have
gotten clean this way yes and they have
it they have an 87
success rate for the people that do 90
days
now a lot of them only do 45 some of
them only do 60 days
and then i would say probably more than
half of the people that went there
uh ended up leaving because of how hard
it was but the only reason they wanted
people there is if you really truly
wanted
to get sober right because for years
you've been stuck in the cycle of
addiction
and for me the easiest way i mean they
explained it and i drawn it on
white boards a lot but for me whenever
you
have that first use you would have this
what they call an
allergy set off you you have an abnormal
reaction
to a to a substance just like someone
else can't have peanuts
i can't have drugs or alcohol because
when i do an allergy goes off that says
in my body i have an abnormal reaction
that says
you know i know rationally that one is
too many
but whenever i have that first use a
thousand is not enough
i got to keep having it and this is
explained to you by these people at this
rehab or this is just your own
feeling no no this was explained and
there's this doctor that's really great
his name's dr
uh kevin and he's got like a irish last
name but he's
he's got some stuff on i think netflix
and amazon and
he was a navy um surgeon and basically
like
he ended up writing himself scripts for
oxy
and then he was injecting himself with
other stuff and
he got put in a a prison a military
prison that one that got taken down in
uh like kansas i forget what it's called
but anyway leavensworth or something
like that he was put in that prison
anyways now he spent his time there
really trying to help people
in addiction and that cycle of addiction
basically is explained as
after you have that first use and that
allergy set off now you go on your spree
because what that doctor did while i
brought him up was he
shows scientifically through brain
research
that addict's brain brain's different
like they don't have enough dopamine
receptors
and whenever that hits now all of a
sudden it goes back to that almost
hunter-gatherer brain
where it says this is a priority for
survival
like that's why some addicts will
prioritize it above food
or water or family and you see them do
irrational things
and then they go on this run and then
when they after after that spree after
that run
they come out of it and they emerge
remorseful they feel terrible
i've had moments like that and then all
of a sudden you
you make a firm resolution that's what
you back it up with is that what you
felt
when you did it the first 30 days you
did it for 30 days
yeah i came out i emerged remorseful and
then i promised myself
i promised my wife at the time i
promised my family
uh friends that this isn't who i want to
be
and and what they say about an addict is
you could hook them up to a lie detector
and they absolutely 100 mean it that
they never intend to use again
but then what happens is they back with
that firm resolution i promise
this was the last time all of a sudden
you get restless irritable and
discontented
well whenever an addict gets wrestle's
irritable discontented i i would ask the
question what's the what's the
difference between discontent and
discontented
you know this can discontent you might
be a little restless but discontented
basically says well if discontent is i'm
thirsty discontented is
there's not enough water in the whole
world to quench this thirst
and so you get in that place where you
have this mental obsession so you have
this mental obsession you get restless
irritable and discontented and then you
go back to that first
use and then you get stuck in that cycle
of addiction again and that's where i
lived for five years from 17 to 23
was i was just looping back and forth so
you get sober for a little bit
then go back again from 17 to 23 no i
wouldn't get so
hardly at all i would get sober for my
fights the eight weeks of fight camp ten
weeks of fight camp
nothing that's why um
that's why grudge training center had to
kick me out you know i mean brendan was
on that vote i think rashad
nate marcourt um shane carwin
uh duane bang ludwig all those guys that
invited me on
the team after i got off the ultimate
fighter it was just a short
while later that they were having to ask
me to leave the team
it was like a vote elliot marshall
trevor whitman
i think justin gates was just starting
to come up i don't know if he was
actually training full time then
but he was still at north northern
colorado state or northern colorado
wrestling there but they said you know
justin like um
you we love you but you gotta go you
gotta go get help and i should have went
and got helped
but that's when i found my purpose with
the pygmies i i've heard this quote that
said
no act of kindness no matter how small
ever goes wasted and so i started at the
local children's hospital
became a local volunteer went through
night school for it
later you remember hdnet and inside mma
with boss rooting
yeah um those guys came out to the
denver children's hospital
this was like nine months of me being
sober all of a sudden now i have rashad
visiting
um the kids at the in shane carwin
dwayne bang brennan shop visiting the
kids that i would
push around in the wheelchairs and stuff
it gave me purpose so and that purpose
helped me stay
sober sorry so 2020 this was the first
time you had had anything
since 2000 and like when
uh it wasn't i i'd had three pretty big
relapses so
so 10 whole years of sobriety pretty
much but i had relapsed three times in
that time oh in the ten years in the ten
years i'd realized for 30 days i'd
relapse for nine days and then relapse
for five days
oh because these are different relapses
yeah this is not the ones you're talking
about the recent ones with your shoulder
uh no that let in that five day then led
into
a big a big one i'll go ahead and i was
confused
because when you said 30 days no i
thought you meant this year
no no not this year um basically
march to may 15th
when i was out i was out there using and
um
i felt so much shame and so much guilt
um because
i mean i've i've been on your show i've
been doing good things i've been
um really trying to live the right life
and my marriage failed which is okay
that happens and i just took on a lot of
like shame i couldn't
i couldn't you know have that
relationship be a success
then whenever i went back to weed all of
a sudden that weed i i just
kept going more and more and more and
more and then often i found oxy then
also i
found coke so you started with weed yeah
but then i went right to the oxy and i
would i would what i would do as
in my addict mind i would think it would
sound rational i'll just have weed so i
don't go back to oxy
and and that will help me with pain if
i'm injured because i i'd actually hurt
my neck training with raphael a little
bit
and um he was sweeping me and i i put my
head out whenever i put my head out i
crunched
right on top of my my neck or my head
and it just sent this like crunch down
into my
cervical neck and it was hurting
i was hurting um more emotionally and i
was stuffing it i wasn't looking at it i
was stuffing it stuffing it stuff in it
and then what happened was i felt so
much shame i told i told my board i
needed rehab
and i said i need i need help like i've
relapsed
i need help and they've always supported
me but i was scared that would they
support me in this
you know if i'm the leader of the
organization or the founder and the
spokesperson
you know we got an incredible internal
team but like
we've had donors from thousands uh
thousands of donors from all 50 states
and 59 countries
you know did i just let everybody down
you know
and is this going to be taken from me as
this life of purpose that i found
you know am i going to lose it all um
and i felt so much shame
they were going to send me to a place in
oklahoma not not to knock it at all
but i had known people from the recovery
world because i had been going and
sharing my story of recovery
in rehabs in in uh in
uh different silver living homes and now
i'll send them back to where they are
what is this rehab place you said this
hard ass rehab place that has a an
amazing
percentage of people get successful it's
it's out of dallas fort worth
and it's called stonegate and i don't
think they advertise it is that hard
but it is that hard and i wanted a place
once i talked to him i realized like
so they get their chewing [ __ ] they do
they actually
they did yell at me really i had a 21
year old kid yelling at me that was
what uh over a green towel did you want
to tackle them
uh i was just like bro i kind of wanted
to at first
uh what they think is they got to humble
you and i'm like me and life has humbled
me
that's why i'm here right and i've been
humbled enough and now i came here to
get help
and but their whole thing is if if
there's no [ __ ] if they get to you
to actually look at your
if they call you on your your [ __ ] why
would then you can start working through
it
yelling at you over a green towel
because you were only allowed to have
white towels that they gave you so you
get there they give you walmart shoes
they give you paper underwear
and they give you this hideous butt
paper paper underwear why they have
paper underwear uh because they
they take your clothes and they put them
in a hot box and then they try to kill
if there's any because there's guys
coming from all over the place right
and um i mean we had people that were
ivy league professors professional
athletes
i'm not sure what people also know from
like homeless shelters and what do you
mean hot pockets
hot box kills any of the the like bed
bugs oh so if someone were to bring bed
bugs in
um and get in the mattresses and things
like that like if someone came from a
homeless shelter or from the streets
how could they afford it uh i don't know
honestly i think there was like a
scholarship program because some of the
people were paying 895 dollars a day
there
but that i think that's what they charge
insurance um
it was expensive man so i just went
through the divorce and i
i basically gave the finances we had so
she could go back to school and i was
going to restart
and then um then also i needed rehab and
that's expensive
um insurance helped but then i had do
you find yourself
this is a weird question but i think
it's
i think it's valid do you find yourself
always in like a new problem
do you do you create problems do you
think
i think i try to help find a solution to
problems but i think for me
um you asked me a question after we got
the treatment on our shoulders or knees
and
you asked what are you manifesting to
have this like sickness you know these
all these sicknesses inside of you
i think now i don't that's not exactly
know i said it
i said do you wonder if you were getting
that you're right because sometimes
people do
you wonder if you're bringing this into
your life yeah sometimes people do
create
problem it's like fine they find
themselves in this eternal state of
conflict
like some people they figure their way
through life with very little conflict
they're magical people
i know a few of them it's rare some
people are constantly
engaged in some insurmountable problem
and then they also go and like in your
case
you find insurmountable problems like
what you're doing with the congo
and the pygmies in uganda and and
helping these people like
it gives you purpose and it helps you
define
your life in a positive way yeah then
when you're not there
problems come up again like all kinds of
major problems there's always
something right i've had some health
problems for sure
and then these relapses that had
happened were
really tough the the biggest one was
this one
in march and let me let me tell you what
happened because
i didn't want to go to this rehab in
oklahoma that that i had known
people that were there that talked it
had a reputation for
people using while they're even there
because they could have their phones at
five pm
they could have visitors they could go
to walmart two or three days a week
and then you can call your your
connection and they could leave it to
you at walmart they could throw it over
the gate and it's on 110 acres and they
can
send you a picture of where it's at
right and you can just go dig it up or
find it and use and
i wanted a place where there that i
wasn't going there
for that i knew i was going to get sober
but i didn't want to be around other
people so they take your phone
away from that yeah you don't have your
phone paper underwear paper underwear
you can uncomfortable or paper underwear
it's terrible
but you get it back uh the next day or
that night after he gets out of the
hotbox
one day that's how i get my towels back
i brought nice towels
and i got they gave me my towels back
well this guy's doing room checks
room checks are every day at least once
a day
and uh anyways they found my green
towels it's my first like 24 hours being
there at our youtube
know that i know you can't have green
towels they give them them back to me
so also i was using that and he gave me
an infraction for uh and if you get
three infractions you lose your phone
call that week
you don't get you don't even get one
phone call until you've been in there
three full weeks because normally when
guys go to rehab
and then they start calling their
families they start feeling like i gotta
get out of here i gotta get home
you start telling yourself this like my
family's more important to take care of
than me
right now when really you're in crisis
mode and you got to take care of
yourself before you can take care of
anyone else
and so um i gotten two infractions for
the two
green towels i had and i was about to
lose my phone call at the three week
mark and uh if because you're getting
three if you get three infractions in
those first three weeks you lose your
phone call
i got two for things i didn't even know
i couldn't have what was the other one
um no that was the green towel he took
one green towel he started walking off
with it looked back and saw in my
like cubby that there was another green
towel there so you got two infractions
for the same thing right
and so um what a dick so but but
i would say that the counselors that
were there and the recovery advocates
they're really hard on you because some
of the guys that have left there
if they let them leave they're over
confident that they've got their problem
nicked um then they can go right back
out and relapse
so how do they keep you from doing it
again
for me well they can't you have to keep
yourself from doing it no one can keep
me sober
no no no therapist no sponsor it's got
to be
me but what what do they do to give you
the tools
to let you do it yourself i think you
really start to
unwind the the tangled web of
why um you use
and for me it's always been like
self-worth it's been
uh like that bullying moment when i was
a kid
my my record can go right back to the
three things the kids told me
and so i dressed up for a costume party
i went um
to my middle school crush's birthday
party i crushed there because i was
dressed up like a dr pepper transformer
your 24 pack i had 12 packs on my arms
i went all out everyone was excited
because she loved transformers
optimus prime i went as dr optimus
pepper
anyways i get there go the backyard when
the door opens i get hit with a couple
flashes of light
and it's them taking pictures i hear the
sound of laughter i see that no one else
is dressed up
and my middle school crush said i can't
believe you thought you were good enough
to come to my party
right next to her a boy said you're
worthless
and then my notorious bully from like
third eighth grade said you should just
kill yourself
and so that leads to basically
whenever i would relapse i would say to
myself you're not good enough you're
worthless
maybe you should just kill yourself you
know i was suicidal at 13
i didn't kill myself because my mom i
thought what would this do to her
do you still go back to that one day
like that one day when you were a child
hurt you so badly that's that's still in
your mind
almost as like a benchmark for who you
are
i did and that's why i think i've really
come
to a place of like self-love seeing
myself that like
when i'm needed well the last six months
but this is after your ufc career after
your bellator career
yeah all the amazing things you've done
with fight for the forgotten
all the time we built the congo i would
know it but when i would relapse
i would feel like such a piece of
garbage
i would feel like i was a disappointment
to myself
but also to everybody else catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience